[Music]
well in just a few days allegiant
stadium will host the pro bowl and
events like that the pro bowl having a
really positive impact in our city joe
moeller spoke to a couple of businesses
who are really thankful to have these
events joe's live outside of allegion
that's right we have a lot of events
happening throughout this year big
sporting events take a look at allegion
stadium here this evening you can see
they are getting ready for the pro bowl
today i spoke to a woman who says this
is bringing her business and even
creating jobs
my workers are happy they're you know
they're willing to work rosa ingrid from
elf entertainment says her labor workers
are setting up at allegiant stadium for
the pro bowl football yeah we've
definitely seen a big rise in work for
our labor workers she says events like
this are big right now it's actually
great for the business it's been so slow
with ces being cancelled left and right
we had a lot of gigs canceled and that
really brought a lot of the spirits down
for workers so provo really you know
rolled some spirits up the shrine bowl
is thursday pro bowl is sunday and we
have the nfl draft bringing hundreds of
thousands of people this spring not to
mention the super bowl in just a few
years these are huge events that are
bringing you know tens of thousands of
people analytics officer for the raiders
jeremy aguero says these are all
bringing in a lot of money we already
know that numbers even in just really a
little more than the first half of the
year is already exciting
several businesses are noticing more
money coming in with pro football here
out of all its offerings it can have now
now it has a sports offering rolando
espinoza from champaign creative group
has more companies around the country
wanting to host business events at
allegion stadium vegas has a special
reputation
now sports has really opened that box
with the success football is bringing to
our city rosa says the more sports in
vegas the better i'm hoping that we get
the baseball stadium
rosa is also saying that she is hiring
at this time with all these events going
on she's hoping that the upcoming
grammys and the draft will give her even
more jobs to fill reporting outside of
religious stadium joe mohler live local
now